Dear friends of VisualPolitik.
Bolivia has recently undergone a whirlwind
of events.
Elections, electoral fraud, civil revolution
and finally, something that seemed impossible:
The fall of Evo Morales.
We’re going to tell you the story of how
Evo Morales went from having all the power,
to giving up the presidency and even being
on the run and caught.
Listen up.
On October 20th, 2019, general elections were
held in the country.
That night, after the results were announced,
social peace exploded.
Since then the protests and demonstrations
of both the opposition and the supporters
of the ruling party, Evo Morales’s supporters,
occurred relentlessly in the country’s main
cities in what some call the “Bolivian spring”.
(AUDIO: The La Paz airport turned into a battlefield,
a city hall devoured by flames and tear gas
shot at the innumerable blocking points installed
throughout the country.
BBC)
The situation was so tense that there was
even a police riot.
(AUDIO: Police riot against Evo Morales, who
denounces a coup d'etat.
The first to rebel was the Tactical Unit of
Police Operations in the central city of Cochabamba,
and shortly after other cities’ commands
rioted.
El Comercio)
All this is related to something we already
predicted, here on VisualPolitik.
We told you how Evo Morales had fallen in
love with power, how he’d ignored the current
law in order to run for president again, and
how everything indicated that he’d stop
at nothing to stay in power.
Even if that meant following the rule-by-force
strategy that has kept characters like Nicolás
Maduro, Daniel Ortega or Juan Orlando Hernández
in power.
Power at any price.
Well, that's exactly what’s happened.
But having said that, let’s see exactly
how events unfolded in Bolivia.
(A FORETOLD STORY)
This whole story began on February 21st, 2016.
That day, 51% of Bolivians rejected the modification
of article 168 of the Constitution in a referendum.
This Constitution, which clearly prohibits
the re-election of an individual for more
than one term of office, was approved at Evo
Morales’s own request.
(AUDIO: “The President and Vice President’s
term of office is 5 years and he or she may
only be reelected once continuously.”
Article 168 of the Bolivian Constitution)
Faced with this situation, with a Constitution
that you yourself approved and that is so
clearly laid out, and having lost a referendum
to modify it, you’d probably say...
Ok, I respect the rules, another candidate
should run for my party.
Right?
At least that’s what happens in every country
with a minimum respect for the law.
Well...
, Evo wouldn’t.
Leave power?
No way.
And, as in every country where the government
has power over all the institutions, it didn’t
aim to work for the public good, but for the
good of the government itself.
Thus, in 2017, the Plurinational Bolivian
Constitutional Court published the grotesque
0084/2017 judgment by which articles of the
Constitution itself were declared unconstitutional,
which included article 168, therefore allowing
for indefinite reelections.
How?
Welcome to Evo Morales’s Bolivia.
The fact is that the Constitutional Court’s
controversial decision was a huge blow to
Bolivia’s rule of law: in the end it didn’t
matter what the Constitution said or what
the Bolivians themselves voted for.
The only thing that mattered was what Evo
Morales wanted.
And faced with this situation, large numbers
of Bolivian society took to the streets to
protest under the cry “Bolivia said No”.
But... here’s another question, do you think
this affected Evo Morales at all?
Did it make him rethink his position or try
to reach an understanding with most of Bolivia’s
society who had voted against his re-election?
Well...
Obviously not.
Evo made it clear that what he wants is power...
At any cost.
[TEXT: That’s why we’re here with a political
liberation project, with a people government
program.]
But, things did start changing at that time.
The government had played fair and lost the
referendum.
So they made sure that when the time came,
they wouldn’t lose at the polls again.
And you know what?
It was a done deal.
From that moment strange, abnormal, unheard
of situations began to happen.
Check it out.
Many members and officials of the Supreme
Electoral Tribunal resigned due to the government’s
very strong pressure; there had been a very
suspicious electoral roll increase of 190%
between 2005 and 2019.
A spectacular growth that evidently doesn’t
match population growth for the same period
of time.
And things got even worse as the elections
approached.
The ruling party, the MAS, the
Movement towards Socialism, didn’t hesitate
to use State resources to campaign, without
the electoral authorities saying anything
of course.
Meanwhile these same authorities were busy
censoring independent surveys that didn’t
declare Evo Morales a winner.
For example, that happened with the surveys
prepared by the Higher University of San Andrés.
Just a second, why would the government censor
surveys?
Think about it for a moment, if you’re going
to commit fraud, you want to make sure it’s
not too scandalous, right?
On top of that, the only company authorized
to perform the quick vote count on election
day was Viaciencia, a company that’s less
than a year old.
That sounds like a good idea; giving control
of a large and complex electoral process to
a newly created and inexperienced company.
And there you have it.
The road towards electoral fraud was paved.
So do you want to know exactly how Evo Morales
stole the elections?
Well...
Listen up.
(THE GREAT HEIST)
The Supreme Electoral Tribunal, Bolivia’s
highest electoral authority, promised to deliver
100% of the quick count results by eight o'clock
on election night.
Well...
Do you know what happened?
When the time came, the Electoral Tribunal
delivered 83% of the count results, not all
of them, and the electoral results broadcast
was suspended without any notice or clarification.
By that time, the preliminary results marked
a clear trend: Evo Morales was winning in
the first round with 45.28% over Carlos Mesa,
the main opposition candidate, who’d obtained
38.16%.
Therefore, there was only a 7.12% difference
between the two candidates which, according
to article 167 of the Constitution, would
lead to a second round.
You see, article 167 of the Bolivian Constitution
states that the candidate who gets 50% of
the votes will be declared President.
Alternatively, if a candidate gets more than
40% of the vote with 10 points ahead of the
candidate with the second highest votes, he
or she can also be declared president.
If these conditions aren’t met, a second
round must be held.
A second round in which, given the results,
victory wasn’t quite so certain for Evo
Morales.
However, we’ve already told you that Evo
wasn’t willing to lose power.
What’s more, he had a plan.
The following day, and after more than 17
hours of unexplained suspended coverage, the
Fast-Preliminary Results Transmission jumped
from 83% to 95%, only to be suspended again
until finally five, five days later, 100%
of the official vote count was reached.
And surprise, surprise, the results were suddenly
very different.
There was to be no second round, Evo had beat
his rival by more than 10 points.
And that’s when everything kicked off.
Thousands and thousands of citizens began
to amass in front of the Electoral Tribunal
and suspicion of fraud ran wild.
No survey, no poll nor any statistical program
had foreseen such a vote deviation.
A deviation at the end of the count that was
completely opaque and happened amid serious
irregularities in the counting process.
This is what led to protests throughout the
country, protests that fundamentally demanded
one thing: clean elections.
As you can imagine the government’s first
reaction was to try to stifle the protests
through repression using the state security
forces.
And that was that.
Far from seeking a solution to the problem,
what Evo did was to denounce an alleged coup
against him, against him, a president who
didn’t hesitate to ignore his own constitution
and deploy all state institutions for his
personal service.
Now, at this point some of you may be thinking….
But, Simon, was the fraud, the electoral robbery,
really so blatant?
Well, frankly, everything points to yes.
Practically all the independent players agree
on this.
For example, international organizations that
acted as observers during the elections, such
as the European Union or the Organization
of American States observers, have recommended
holding a second round because the official
result cannot be accepted.
(AUDIO: “Every election must be governed
by the principles of certainty, legality,
transparency, fairness, independence and impartiality...
the Mission was able to verify that several
of these principles have been violated through
different paths throughout this electoral
process.”
Report from the Organization of American States
Observers.)
And that’s not all.
Even civil society members spotted a lot of
irregularities.
For example, there’s the case of the computer
systems engineer Edgar Villegas who, along
with a team of professionals, has worked on
comparing the official calculation tables
with the results transmission.
His conclusion was that the process was full
of traps, which included the elimination of
voting results tables, to favor MAS, Evo Morales’s
party.
And there’s more, check this out:
(AUDIO: Bolivia: the official audit described
the elections as “null and void” and Carlos
Mesa demanded new elections.
The company hired by the Supreme Electoral
Tribunal delivered a report stating that it
cannot “attest to the integrity of the results”
of the presidential elections held last October
20th.
InfoBae)
As you can see, not even the company that
the Electoral Tribunal itself hired, which
has fully backed Evo in the past, dares to
validate the results.
The fraud is too evident.
And finally, the Organization of American
States observers’ preliminary report was
very much in the same vein: fraud, deceit,
scams, a mockery of the popular will, all
of this was evident.
Evo Morales wanted to become a leader, just
like his friends Nicolas Maduro or Daniel
Ortega, who as you all know are experts in
ignoring the democratic process.
Anyone who’s been following Bolivia’s
political news knows one thing: Evo Morales
was going to try to stay in power no matter
what.
However, the street protesters didn’t want
to see Evo become a new Nicolas Maduro and
the bungling and scandalous way in which he
tried to perpetrate electoral robbery meant
his shot backfired.
The police began to mutiny so they wouldn’t
have to comply with the government's repression
orders.
And that, along with the mass protests that
were taking place in the country, led Evo
to announce a call for new elections.
[TEXT: “Calling for new national elections
that, through the vote, allow the Bolivian
people to democratically elect their new authorities”]
But was the same person who committed the
fraud going to organize and stand for election
again?
What credibility would that process have?
Merely repeating the elections was no longer
enough.
The people on the streets, the opposition
parties, the independent media...
All the forces outside MAS had begun demanding
the President’s resignation.
And finally, the army followed suit:
In fact, that was the last straw; without
the people, without the police and without
the army, Evo Morales was forced to hand in
his resignation and resign from Bolivia’s
presidency.
(AUDIO: Bolivia’s Morales resigns amid scathing
election report, rising protests.
Washington Post)
But... just a second, because the drama didn’t
end there.
This is what followed:
(AUDIO: Evo Morales travels to Mexico on a
plane owned by the López Obrador Government.
- France 24)
And so, that’s how Evo Morales’s time
in Bolivia came to an end.
After his departure, the new transition government
has announced a call for new elections, elections
that will be supervised by international organizations.
Fine, the procedure may not have been the
best, but Bolivian democracy was at stake.
Evo would’ve had to leave, but he got drunk
with power and decided to turn Bolivia into
his own personal playground.
Of course, it doesn't end there.
Bolivia now faces not only a deep institutional
conflict but also significant economic imbalances.
Evo’s most recent years were bad, very bad,
and the future is far from clear.
The country needs a complete change of course.
But we’ll talk about all of that in an upcoming
video.
So now, it’s your turn.
Do you think Evo's departure will be good
for Bolivia?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.